it's time for stage 2 the strip down
cue the mega machines
it's almost month two of the demolition
the famous Miami Orange Bowl turf is
gone so the stadium is demco is for the
taking
they need to systematically rip strip
and prep the nine story stadium until
they expose its skeletal structure
the first item on the menu this lower
section of field seats it's a mega job
that calls for mega machinery
first up the mammoth 110 ton Komatsu TC
1000 excavator its hydraulic arm extends
to heights of 50 feet and its claw-like
shear attachment crushes with a force on
five thousand pounds per square inch
see through anything about this the
concrete tears that steal apart no
problem it's joined by its baby brother
the cat 320
together the tag team takes on the bowl
it's a bowl full of steel and aluminum
salad ready for recycling both materials
will be shipped out cut down melted and
ultimately reformed the aluminum will be
transformed into everything from window
frames to car parts the steel will go on
to become Reba and other products at the
end of just one month of work demco has
already done some serious damage